and what types of female roles do you
like to watch in other actresses that's
really interesting i think there's
definitely been
an increase in female-led movies i mean
you know we saw kiplan should accept her
oscar and say that you know we're we're
finally starting to grasp that i love to
see strong women on on film but i also
really like to see
you know
strong women who have a vulnerable side
as well because i think that complexity
is where you know reality lies um
and sometimes female characters can be
shoved to one side so it's great to see
when there's a female lead who has
real substance
excellent thank you
you